hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde da Sandra mit mir ungern Videos
an meinem Schreibtisch aufnimmt weil der
Schreibtischstuhl dann so hoch ist dass
ihre Beine in der Luft schweben und
dadurch ihre Beine immer Einschlafen
habe gesagt wir nehmen heute meine nicht
lachen Challenge auf dem Sofa auf und
dann habe ich ein paar tiktoks
rausgesucht die ich schon kenne
allerdings die dir zeigen möchte Telefon
erste nicht lachen Challenge und hast du
gelacht nein
[Musik]
wenn ich jetzt treffe dann verschwinde
ich aus deinem Leben
keine Sorge ich bin dort für dich kümmer
ich bin für dich da Amana London
keine Sorge ich bin dafür dich für immer
ich bin für dich da Amona London für
immer da London du denkst wirklich das
ist eine Himbeere da muss ich dich
leider enttäuschen das sind tatsächlich
Schneckeneier du den
KST wieder mal der Baum da muss ich dich
leider enttäuschen das ist nämlich mein
hallo Leute herzlich willkommen zu
unserem heutigen Video mein Name ist Max
und das mein Kollege Manfred
hallo mein Name ist max
[Gelächter]
ja auf unserem neuen Kanal
hast du noch mal den Anfang an hallo
Leute herzlich willkommen zu unserem
heutigen Video mein Name ist Max und das
mein Kollege Manfred
was reimt sich auf Bank vielen Dank sie
sind auch sehr schlank
[Musik]
ist eigentlich tödlich sagt der andere
wieso haben wir gerade auf die Zunge
gebissen Müller
[Applaus]
sie gar nicht holen du bist so unlustig
wirklich ne
[Gelächter]
Leute immer schön durchziehen lasst euch
niemals verlocken vor allem wenn so
welche Läden direkt neben dran sind und
was du bei mir bitte auch geriebenen
Käse ja gerne etwas mehr
danke
Arschloch
du findest sonst Schwachsinn
ey bist du total
Opfer davon ausgehen dass jetzt
natürlich der Alkoholkonsum langsam
steigt und nur hoffen dass der schreibt
ist die gesamte Atmosphäre dann noch so
friedlich bleibt wie sie momentan ist
wir müssen erstmal auch sagen die jungen
Menschen wollen
von Köln das war elf der Hälfte
zweieinhalb Zentimeter Kreditkarten von
sämtlichen konnten die ich habe ich habe
alle Banker schon angerufen dass sie es
freischalten heute bin ich am Start
es geht los Mittagessen kaufst du mir
dann auch was nein ich kaufe ich liebe
diesen Typ mehr
[Musik]
haben Dinge die man nicht essen kann
Kalorien haben Gegenstände Kalorien
Leute haben Gegenstände Kalorien
wenn ich jetzt jemanden würde
stimmt bestimmt
Naturwissenschaft
danke schön
Migrationshintergrund nein
wir sind neu ausgezogen
für Leipzig und für Schachter Ton jetzt
Videos so lustig ich liebe Papageien
haben meine Freundin hat einfach gerade
mit mir Schluss gemacht wisst ihr aus
welchem Grund nur weil ich schwul bin
das ist so homophob
verstehst du gut mit runter du hast no
oh skin
er ist runter hast direkt ein Epic will
in du spielst drei Tage lang hast du die
30 Kronen Siege du spielst Arena hast
die Championsleague du fehlst es den
kleinen face Clan redest du bei du
besiegt jeden und sogar
warum aber ich will wirklich zusammen
raus noch nicht weinen ja damals war es
so dass meine damalige Freundin gehabt
jetzt Ex-Freundin immer wenn wir im Auto
waren hat sie zu mir gesagt sie sollen
machen kann und ich habe jedesmal
gedacht sie kann ich jetzt einen raus
aber sie hat immer nur diesen Song
gemacht in den meisten Fällen wenn er
privat bei mir im Auto läuft dann gebe
ich den Song das sind Wunden die werden
die heilige egal wie sehr Du darüber
hinweg bist egal wie lange du mit der
Person nicht mehr zusammen sind bist
[Musik]
bei Minecraft mit diesem ganzen Sheltern
und so sieht übel für Rechenleistung vom
PC
aber
sind so was ist die Lieblingsfrucht von
Cristiano Ronaldo boah ich denke mal
Wassermelone
[Musik]
nein wo ein dein Job verlieren kann
guckt einfach alle Deko doof tiktoks
alle sind ultra witzig ich glaube ich
habe eine Zecke
boah dann geh weg darf nicht zu mir
rüber springen Bruder
mein Blut ist süßer
hey Süßer ich heiße süße
Video da abonniert meinen Kanal klickt
auf die Glocke jetzt nicht zu verpassen
wenn die abonnieren wollt kann ich das
auch total gut verstehen
Telefon
[Musik]
[Applaus]